hey youtubers is Charlie so the big news
is that they've been talking about the
Harley Quinn movie and they're calling
it Harley Quinn in the birds of prey
which sets off a bunch of warning alarms
in your head so I'm gonna talk a little
bit about what's going on with that in
how that ties in with the Batman movie
that's coming up because they just
started working on it they're already
almost done with the Batman script so
that movie will come before the Harley
Quinn birds-of-prey movie which is
really important because there are a
couple key birds of prey characters that
are missing from the DC extended
universe that the Batman movie could
totally introduce but they haven't
really confirmed anything so I'm going
to start with the Harley Quinn
birds-of-prey movie then talk about how
the Batman movie can help that out
without completely sidelining the Batman
movie you don't have to shoehorn too
many things into that Batman movie you
just want it to be like a really awesome
Batman movie and if they have a couple
opportunities to introduce or tease
characters that could be in birds of
prey then I'm all down for that so
Harley Quinn and the birds of prey what
the hell's going on they just hired
someone to write the script so that
gives you an idea where they are in the
process they still have a long long ways
to go they haven't officially confirmed
with the roster is going to be but I
think the title birds of prey gives you
a couple pretty clear ideas so why would
they go with that title instead of say
Harley Quinn in the Joker or Harley
Quinn in the Gotham City sirens or
something like that or just call it
Harley Quinn well I think one they're
trying to load the title so that it
sounds like a movie that non comic-book
people would go see like Harley Quinn is
a really big character if you read
comics that you probably read some
version of Harley Quinn at some point
but compared to the larger movie-going
audience even the people that went to
see Suicide Squad you know might not be
quite as down to buy movie tickets for a
movie that just Harley Quinn so I will
say that I did think margot robbie was
really awesome in Suicide Squad she did
a really good job with the character so
I do think she's capable of carrying a
movie but you can only add so many
characters to a movie before you have to
start adding things in the title like
you put Batman and Superman in the same
movie you can't just call it a Batman
movie you have to put Superman in the
title somewhere so you have Harley Quinn
in a movie you put the Joker in there
you put people like Barbara Gordon
put people like the Huntress Black
Canary you have to change the title just
a little bit you can't just call it a
Harlequin movie but it sounds like what
they're trying to do it just balance the
heroes in the villains in the movie a
little bit like the idea that they would
put some of the birds of prey in the
movie allows Harley Quinn to still be a
villain in the movie but be the
protagonist so it sounds like they
didn't want to do a straight-up villain
movie like you put a couple more heroes
in there you allow the tone to be a
little more hopeful in the right places
it just balances the film a little bit
better and you have the opportunity to
do some really cool comic book
characters that you have not done in the
movies yet so whereas Gotham City sirens
would have been Harley Quinn Catwoman in
poison ivy now it sounds like what it's
going to be is Harley Quinn Catwoman in
a couple of the birds of prey
maybe not everybody from the comics but
if you're not familiar with the history
of the birds of prey in the comics it
actually just started out with Black
Canary in Barbara Gordon
but then when Gail Simone came on the
title she added Huntress to the mix the
team grew a little bit so I think the
two big characters that they definitely
need to get into the DC movie universe
are Catwoman in Barbara Gordon everybody
else is kind of up for grabs
those are just like the two biggest ones
I think they definitely need to get in
there but I don't think you can call it
a birds-of-prey movie if you're only
adding like one or two characters from
the birds of prey so here's the thing
though the birds of prey team actually
grew quite a bit during the new 52 so
poison ivy Catwoman were members of the
birds of prey team at various points so
I'll just go down the list here there
are a bunch of members is just that most
people remember the classic lineup and
since doing rebirth like the big DC
rebirth of ethane the comics they've
gone back to that classic Gail Simone
roster but when you blow it out here's
the extended roster so there's Catwoman
Lady Black Hawk big Barda that's
actually pretty crazy one I don't think
they're gonna do her in the movies
anytime soon Jade canary gypsy Hawkgirl
judo master the Kate Spencer Manhunter
misfit Hawk dub Starling katana and we
already have her in the movie so there
PI put her in there poison ivy Strix in
Condor so you're thinking about the list
and you're like who could they shoehorn
into this movie without it getting
ridiculous well katana was pretty badass
in Suicide Squad but she wasn't really
that big a character they could do more
with her and this they could introduce
Catwoman they could introduce Black
Canary and Barbara Gordon but the thing
is is that's a lot of new characters so
here's where we get to the Batman movie
so because most of these characters are
actually Batman characters I mean Batman
is one of the biggest comic book
characters ever so like when you look at
DC's roster of characters the odds are
pretty good that they either came from a
Batman title a Superman title or one
like the Justice League team-up titles
so I think what they need to do during
that Batman movie is introduced the
Barbara Gordon character in the Catwoman
character you know you don't have to
like shoehorn any other characters in
you could totally save Black Canary if
they're going to do her in the movies
for the birds of prey movie it's totally
okay to introduce like one or two new
characters in each new movie but I think
after the reaction to Suicide Squad
they're going to try and avoid
introducing too many characters at the
same time so most of the really big
characters that you see in Harley Quinn
and the birds of prey will probably be
people that you've seen before in other
DC movies in various capacities Harley
Quinn CH is going to be the biggest one
but I know I haven't talked about the
Joker a lot obviously he would have some
role in any Harley Quinn movie they kind
of come as a pair but what I'm really
hoping they do with him is that they
tease Harley Quinn sort of breaking off
on her own like she sees Catwoman she
sees the birds of prey recognizes their
independence realizes that she doesn't
have to be with the Joker so they can
just have a little bit of fun with their
relationship they're always going to
come as a pair regardless of what their
current status is like the Joker is
always going to be obsessed with Harley
Quinn but part of the fun of the Harley
Quinn character is that once she
recognizes that she doesn't need the
Joker she just goes off and does
whatever she wants like she doesn't
worry about what the Joker thinks of her
even though he is always somewhere on
her mind but the really big question now
is you know birds of prey Black Canary
what does this say about them doing
Black Canary on the TV shows because we
know Laurel Lance is coming back to
arrow but in a number of different
capacities so if you haven't been
watching arrow just like really quick
catch up they have a Black Canary
character they actually had a couple
different black
arrey characters so they kind of mess
with the character over the course of a
couple seasons so spoiler warning God
knows a spoiler warning for Black Canary
on arrow they killed her off during
season four but then because of lazarus
pit resurrection time travel all kinds
of comic book twists they're bringing
the actress back on the show but the
producers haven't really explained
exactly how she's going to work like if
she's going to be full-blown Black
Canary when she comes back or if they're
not going to do that character again and
I don't think that's the case I think
they'll eventually do Black Canary again
on the TV shows there was all kinds of
news about the Suicide Squad in the
movies kind of killing off the Suicide
Squad on the TV show and I definitely
think there was some influence but that
was pre geoff johns era in the movies
and i think they're a little bit nicer
about the TV shows using movie
characters like we know the Deathstroke
is going to appear during the arrow
hundredth episode but he's also going to
be a big part of the batman movie and
even Justice League so like Superman was
on Supergirl
but they only let him go on for the
first two episodes he'll come back on
briefly he can't be in every single
episode so even though you do see movie
stuff happening on the TV shows there's
still at least a few rules about that
but don't worry about birds of prey in
the movies vs. birds of prey on TV just
let me know who do you want to be in
that birds of prey movie from the comics
like do you want to see movie Black
Canary
obviously everybody wants to see
Catwoman show up eventually just for Ben
Affleck's character that's going to be
so much fun but just remember the way
they're setting this up is still gonna
allow Harley Quinn to be evil but still
be the protagonist of the movie like
she's still gonna be the Harley Quinn
character she's not going to turn good
or anything like that now a lot of you
are asking when is this movie going to
drop well typically it takes about two
years at least two years to get a script
and get a movie made so I plan on late
2018 early 2019 just depending on how
long it takes them to get this script
out and get a director but like I said
when we see that Batman movie I'm really
hoping to see Catwoman in there
somewhere in Barbara Gordon at least in
a small capacity they don't have to be
huge characters just introduce the idea
that they exist so that you can build
them out in other movies but it's going
to be a lot of fun and there should be
some more Justice League stuff happening
in December just be
we'll be about a year away from the
movie so I would expect to start seeing
more footage more stuff from behind the
scenes like I think they've done a good
job marketing the movie to the fans it's
mostly to the fans just to show people
who were dissatisfied with previous
movies look we're making this really
awesome thing we're really excited about
this so I think they're going to
continue to try and do that so even if
we don't see like a full Justice League
trailer I still think that they're going
to release like some small teasers
towards the end of the year so I will be
doing more Justice League stuff as we
get closer to the end of the year be
sure to subscribe to get everything
remember Justice League is coming next
year Justice League and Star Wars
Episode eight are both premiering within
a month of each other that's what's
happening at the end of next year it is
going to be so awesome so I should start
a new round of the DC giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video later
tonight I'll be posting a game of
Thrones video they'll be Walking Dead
and Marvel tomorrow so a whole bunch of
comic book stuff happening while you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here to watch the four night crossover
trailer again and you can click here to
learn all about Steppenwolf and Dark
Side war in the Justice League movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you